this is a quick
test of the zoom system as we're having
a few technical issues here in geneva
welcome participants um this is chris
from the communications department so
please bear with us while we
do a few more tests
foreign
um
[Music]
foreign
voila
[Music]
[Music]
well
foreign
you
hello all i would like to ask for your
patience please we are trying to fix
some
technical problems thank you for
understanding
hello all uh i think our pro uh
technical problems
are being solved now um i am father
speaking to you from who headquarters in
geneva
and i welcome you to our global kovid 19
press conference today friday
8th january present in the room our
who director general dr tedros dr mike
ryan
executive director health emergencies dr
maria von kirkhoff technical lead for
covid19
dr bruce ellward special advisor to dg
and lead on act accelerator dr
marian gilashimao assistant director
general
access to medicines and health products
joining us remotely are dr kate o'brien
director
immunization vaccine and biologicals and
dr
ed kelly director integrated health
services
welcome all we have simultaneous
interpretation
in the six ul languages plus portuguese
and hindi now without further delay i
would like to
invite dr tedros for his opening remarks
dg you have the floor
thank you thank you vedila
good morning good afternoon and good
evening
callbacks set up by gabby
sapi and who in april last year has now
secured contracts of two billion dollars
of safe and effective coveted 19
vaccines
which we're ready to roll out as soon as
the vaccines are delivered
and we also have the right of first
refusal
on an additional 1 billion dollars
however this is where the current
challenge is at present 42 countries are
rolling out
safe and effective covet 19 vaccines
36 of these are high-income countries
and six are middle-income countries
so there is a clear problem that low
and most middle-income countries are not
receiving
the vaccine yet this is a problem
we can and we must solve together
through kovacs
and the act accelerator at the outset
rich countries have bought up the
majority of the supply of multiple
vaccines
now we're also seeing both high and
middle-income countries that are part of
kovacs
making additional bilateral deals
this potentially bumps up the price for
everyone
and means high-risk people in the
poorest and most marginalized countries
don't get the vaccine
and some companies and countries have
not submitted critical data
which we need to issue emergency use
listings
which blocks the whole system of
procurement and delivery
vaccine nationalism hurts us all
and is self-defeating
but on the flip side vaccinating
equitably
saves lives stabilized health systems
and would lead to a truly global
economic recovery
that stimulates job creation
importantly it would also help us limit
the virus opportunity
to mutate the current
variants show that the virus is doing
its best to make itself
more suitable to ongoing circulation
within the human
population this is normal
of every virus but at present we're
helping it
thrive if we don't reduce transmission
and vaccinate equitably going forward
i want to see manufacturers prioritize
supply and roll out through kovacs
i urge countries that have contracted
more vaccines than they will need
and are controlling the global supply to
also donate
and release them to covax immediately
which is ready today
to roll out to roll out them out quickly
and i urge countries and manufacturers
to stop making bilateral deals
at the expense of kovacs no country is
exceptional and should cut the qi
and the queue and vaccinate all their
population
while some remain with no supply of the
vaccine
science has delivered let's not waste
the opportunity to protect lives of
those most at risk
and ensure all economies have a fair
shot
at recovery
it is a massive undertaking to ensure
health system planning
coordination training and logistics are
set
and able to roll out vaccines in the
midst of a coveted 19 surge
the hundred hundred initiative driven by
who unicef and the world bank is
supporting over 100 countries
to conduct rapid readiness assessments
and develop
country specific plans for vaccines
deployment
and we have hit our target 100 countries
have now
completed this critical process and
governments and health systems are on
standby
for global vaccine rollout we're ready
kovacs is ready countries are ready
the time to deliver vaccines equitably
is now
this is a very dangerous time in the
course of the pandemic
and i do not want to see people become
complacent as vaccines are starting to
roll out
over the past few days we have seen some
of the highest numbers of deaths
recurred at
any point in the pandemic
this is happening because over previous
weeks
there has been a lack of compliance with
what else authorities are advising
in several countries
the virus has taken advantage of this
and is spreading at an alarming
rate in some countries
you might think that you would you
wouldn't happen it wouldn't happen
to you and that you don't need to comply
with the measures the problem is that
before you know it
not complying a bit becomes a habit
people you know mimic the behavior
and the whole system breaks down
not complying with recommended measures
gives the virus opportunities to
spread putting you and your loved ones
at risk for infection and for more
people to develop severe diseases and
for more pressure to be put on health
workers people need to know
that they can personally stop the virus
and they need to know that the virus
can stop with them if i said
one thing to people in areas where there
are high numbers of cases
it would be to do all you can to avoid
mixing with people from other households
especially inside
because the virus thrives when people
gather in groups
especially inside where people are less
inclined to physically distance
wear masks and hand wash and where
windows aren't open and there is not
adequate ventilation which means
everyone is sharing the same air
in this difficult period it's best to
meet virtually
but if you have to meet others do it
carefully
and with the right precautions meet
outside
wherever possible none of us are
exceptional
and the more we can break the chains of
transmission
and stop the virus ourselves
the more we will avoid severe cases
and tragic deaths
this year is the year of the health and
care worker
let's show our respect and appreciation
for health workers
and care workers by protecting each
other
and vaccinating all health workers
everywhere now remember
ending this pandemic is one of
humanity's
great races and whether
we like it or not we will win
or lose this race together i thank you
and fedila back to you
thank you dr tedros i will now open the
floor
to questions from journalists i remind
you
that you will need to raise your hand
using the icon
raise your hand to get in the queue
i would like now to invite our first
journalist jeremy lunch from radio
rfi radio international
jeremy can you hear me
yes yes
thank you so much good evening a quick
question on the
new study that suggests that the fisa
vaccine
protects against the new variants of the
kovid
i would like to know if who has more
details on that and if uh and
and what about the other vaccine um
probably uh astrazeneca and modena
do you have info that's there to protect
against the new variants
thank you so much uh thank you jeremy
from radio france international i would
like to invite dr o'brien to take this
question
dr o'brien
thank you for this question um
uh we're we're looking into this uh it's
very recent information
and i think the important thing is the
um
this is going to be a dynamic situation
um and the
evidence uh is going to continue to
accrue so this is welcome information
it's also what has been expected um
understanding where the
variations are um that where the
modifications are that are
are part of these variants so this is um
this is certainly um a dynamic space
and there will be continue to be work
going on to look at
the relationship between these variants
and the vaccines
a number of vaccines coming out and in
particular
i think what is also anticipated is
evidence from efficacy trials that are
being conducted in
areas where the variants are circulating
and that of course will be
some of the most powerful information
that will come out about these vaccines
thank you dr o'brien i would like now to
invite
jamil chad from uol to ask the next
question jamil
yes can you hear me yes very well go
ahead to me
yes thank you for the question padella
my question is probably to
dr uh mike ryan um it's a question about
brazil
could you tell us what is uh in your
view the current situation in brazil
especially in the state of sao paulo
whether you think
it is time as who already asked for
others
uh in terms of europe and other regions
of the world
to make restrictions
um i would say more solid or increase
restrictions at this point of time what
are we now at what point are we in
brazil today
and whether you could comment on the
specific situation
of regions thank you very much
hi jamil this is mary angela i will
come in there i think we are observing
the data from brazil very carefully
and it's actually uh
evolving differently in the different
regions of brazil
right it's welcome news that the
brazilian uh producer bhutan
has uh has issued uh
has made public the the news about the
efficacy of the cenovak vaccine
so we are watching the situation in
brazil as it evolves
and uh of course that um
the different like i said the different
reasons being that
big country the re different regions are
showing different
signs of of either of stabilizing the
epidemic
the number of cases or or increasing
in some region especially in the
southeast in the south of brazil
i don't want i don't know if mike wants
to come
no just just add that like many other
countries the the latest surge in cases
has uh been pretty much uh
countrywide we've seen again the
healthcare system
impacted but it the the number of
available icu beds remains adequate in
most regions although
some areas have now over 70 75 percent
of icu occupants you remember in
previous surges that
went up to nearly 90 or over 90 percent
in some cases so the health system
continues to to cope brazil is
essentially in the same situation that
many many other countries are
dealing with a third surge uh
second surge whatever you you call that
and keeping the health system online is
extremely important the dg
has spoken to what we all need to do to
reduce uh
the the force of transmission within our
our communities those
same advice go to to everybody to
everybody in brazil
and again we're we're all struggling
with this virus at this moment in time
in different countries
for different reasons thank you
maria yeah thanks just to supplement
this to say that it's not brazil
specific but i think it's a good
opportunity to
to remind everyone that the epidemiology
needs to drive the response
so regardless of you know where you are
and what is happening it the data that
is
captured from the systems that countries
have put in place
which are being implemented uh through
the surveillance activities and active
case finding
through your testing through your
cluster investigations
that data should drive what you do next
and so while we see now strong national
plans with strong strategies
the implementation of the public health
and social measures
as those are applied as those are lifted
need to be guided by the epidemiology of
the mo of the local situation
so take in decisions at the most local
level possible
and what we're seeing is what countries
are doing are looking at agile
and tailored approaches based on the
need based on the capacities
and adjusting as necessary and these are
strengths
of the responses that we are seeing at
sub-national levels
course correcting making those
adjustments to what is needed
using your workforce um as best as you
can
the tired and overworked and exhausted
workforce
through contact tracers through those
that are doing lab tests
through those community health workers
that are going door to door to your
front line medical workers use your
workforce as best as you can where they
are
needed but but base it on the data
that's driven
and that is something that i think is
worthwhile reminding because
as we see case numbers go up and down in
many different locations
the response has to be guided by the
epidemiology whether
this is a virus variant or not it needs
to be based on the local epidemiology
that you're seeing
and use the tools that you have on hand
use the vaccines and vaccinations as
they come online
but use everything at your disposal to
reduce the spread
as many as much as we can limit the
number of infections
this will have a positive impact on
reducing the burden on the health system
it will reduce the development of the
number of people that will develop
severe disease
the number of people that will need
hospitalization and ultimately the
number of people that will die
thank you um i would like now to invite
nina larson from ifp to ask the next
question
nina are you with us yes hi can you hear
me
very well go ahead please thanks um
i was hoping you could provide us with
an update on
the international mission to china if
the chinese
officials have provided you with an
explanation for why
visas were not provided earlier this
week and
when you think they'll be expected and
also where
the two experts who set off on tuesday
are now
are they still waiting thank you
dr tedros yeah thank you thank you very
much
so we're in touch with chinese
official officials and they
agreed to share with us the specific
dates for the travel
in the next few days and we will share
with you the specific dates
uh next week and we're also
advised that the visa and other
needs are on there on their way so we
will
give you more details uh next week but
we expect
to fix the travel dates next week thank
you
and i just have to meant to say that the
two
the two uh experts that had begun travel
uh have returned
to their home stations and uh we spoke
with including the directorate general
spoke
uh with them at the weekend but also
today we had a meeting of the
international team
we continued to remain fully committed
to the detailed planning for the mission
on the scientific basis we had a very
good meeting today to discuss that
and we will reach out once again to
continue that scientific collaboration
with the colleagues
on the science side in in in china so we
fully expect to continue that planning
in terms of the the terms of reference
and the objectives of the mission
the specific scientific investigations
and inquiries that need to
move ahead and as the dg said the other
arrangements around the logistics are in
hand
and where we stand ready and are on
standby to move as quickly as
those issues are resolved
thank you i would like now to invite
michael
buserke from cnn opinion to ask the next
question
michael can you hear me
uh yes i can hear you can you hear me
yeah very well go ahead please
super thank you for taking my question
um i
recently had the chance to interview dr
michael
osterholm he is a member of
president-elect joe biden's quote
19 advisory board he said quite grimly
the following
the coronavirus is like a series of
forest fires
looking for human wood to burn likely
well over 65 to 75 percent of the
world's population has yet to be
infected
and uh indeed just today uh la county
said they're
they're observing a test positivity rate
of 20 to 25
so my question is the following given
the slow pace of the vaccine rollout
new spikes in cases in regions that had
earlier crushed the curb
vaccine hesitancy and giving the faster
faster spread of the virus from the
newer stream
what is your best estimate on what
percentage of the world's population
will become
infected at the end of the day after all
is said and done
thank you um
hi thanks and uh
mike has said many very very wise
things right the way through this
pandemic and and continues to do so
um the the reality is that you lay out
some very tough realities that you just
laid out
as part of your question the dg has said
it before we are in the fight of our
lives we're at a moment
when the virus uh transmission is
intensifying because of human being
because of our behaviors it's
intensifying because of
various strains uh and uh
we are continuing to to to track the the
movement of the virus
and as it as uh finds susceptible
individuals and continues to infect them
and mike is correct
in that it is like a series of forest
fires where there are large numbers of
susceptible people and the virus enters
that group it spreads very quickly
and then makes those people with uh who
are vulnerable
very sick and many die um and
the reasons for that are are the way in
which we're mixing and allowing the
virus
uh the reason the the opportunity to
transmit further
the virus is not stopping in each
generation with each individual
the virus is continuing to find ways to
move to the next generation of infection
and causing havoc as it as it does so
the measures that
dg has outlined in the baria emphasized
are still the same measures
we can still stop this virus we can
still interrupt its transmission
we have to double down and recommit
ourselves to that process
mike is correct the vast majority of the
population of this planet still remains
susceptible to infection with this virus
it's very very difficult to come up with
an actual accuracy
figure for how many people have actually
been infected many of the surprise
studies have occurred over the last year
many are six months old at this point so
we're dealing with older data
maria can speak to how we're trying to
address that number but mike is correct
when he says up to what to three
quarters of the population and
potentially more
are are still susceptible to infection
with this fire so this fire
to use his analogy will continue to burn
it will continue to burn until we put
the fire out
we can and need to put this fire out
we need to dampen the intensity of the
flames
we can only do that right now through
the measures we take individually
and collectively and at government level
to do that
we need to use all the tools as maria
said many times
in that toolkit we have the tools we
have the means
to do that the vaccine is rolling out it
will continue to roll out and it will
provide a huge opportunity to save lives
and it will ultimately provide an
opportunity to dampen
and shut down transmission but that day
has not come
yet and we need to buy time we need to
buy
time and save lives until that happens
and if we cannot get vaccines and the dj
has spoken to this
as well we do not want to see a prospect
where we see large proportions of people
vaccinated in some countries and no one
vaccinated in other countries
the people likely to die from this
infection is not everybody in every
country it's
very particular risk groups by age and
by vulnerability
who are likely to get very sick and
likely to die it is frontline health
workers who are exposed to this virus
every day
this is whom we need to protect first
it's not about the overall
percentage of the population that's
susceptible it's not about the overall
percentage of the population will
ultimately be infected
it is are we going to allow those people
who are vulnerable
and those people who are most at risk to
get sick and die from this virus
that is what the dg has spoken to the
need for us now to take a step back
and ensure that we distribute this
vaccine to those who need it
to those who are most vulnerable and
those who are going to benefit most
um but again maria may speak to the the
issues of how we're trying to get to a
better number
in terms of those who are susceptible
and bruce we want to comment on the
on the issues of vaccine distribution
thanks mike so uh yes indeed i i think
the forest fire analogy is really good
one
and if you've heard us speak before many
times about the idea when you think of
transmission as
cases cases sporadic cases and those
sporadic cases could be embers these
could be
little tiny sparks that could
potentially turn into
into small fires which are clusters of
cases
which in those clusters of cases could
turn into wildfires
which are community transmission and all
of the measures that we have outlined
through this comprehensive
all of government all of society
approach is working towards making sure
that those embers
those sporadic cases do not become
little fires or clusters
and that those litter fires of clusters
do not become community transmission
and those wildfires and that is what
countries are showing us that they can
do
and so that fire analogy i think works
really really well
because we have tools in our toolkit
that put out those fires
those tools that we have break those
chains of transmission and prevent the
sporadic cases from becoming clusters
and those clusters from becoming
community transmission and those same
tools help us move from community
transmission
to clusters and from clusters to
sporadic cases
and we've seen that in many many
countries across the world in all
regions of the world
in different types of societies high
income low income
urban rule over and over again and that
will be done again
and vaccines and vaccinations will be
one more powerful tool to help us
put out those fires but with regards to
the serology
indeed there are hundreds of studies
that have been done
that have looked at specific populations
and amongst those populations
how many of those individuals have had
evidence of infection
and so they look at a point in time and
most of those studies have been done
up through the spring and into the
summer in the northern hemisphere
so april may june july
august and they have given us almost a
point estimate
in that population between three
five maybe ten percent of that
population has evidence of infection
what we are working towards through our
unity studies and this is a
program that we have begun in january
where we with our partners have
developed protocols research templates
which we have shared now with more than
100 countries
we are working with them to adapt these
research protocols for the countries
themselves we're providing technical
support operational support
or even providing the serologic assays
that they can use
to follow populations over time so that
we can get estimates of the populations
that have this evidence of infection
and our goal in doing so using a
standardized approach
is to be able to pull that data either
regionally or grow
globally so that we can come up with
estimates to answer the question that
you asked in your question to us today
but we're also looking at the immune
response over time
so some individuals and there's some
recent studies that have even come out
even
today or yesterday that suggest that the
immune response
may be six months or longer and that's
very good news
to show that somebody that was in
infected even if they had mild disease
develop a robust immune response and
that immune response lasts for six
months or longer
so that's good and we're still studying
this so
we while there are hundreds of studies
underway we don't have all of the
answers yet
but the results that come to us that are
shared with us
in real time almost tell us that the
majority of the world remains
susceptible to infection
and therefore we have to do everything
that we can to prevent as many
infections as we can we will emphasize
that every time we have an opportunity
to do so
because this matters every step that you
take
that reduces your exposure reduces the
opportunity for this virus to infect you
and it reduces the opportunity for you
to pass it on to someone else
who may be of a vulnerable group maybe
of an older group
that would develop severe disease need
hospitalization
and potentially die and while we have
gotten better
at treatment there still are a large
number of people who are dying from this
virus
and so it's up to us so as the dg said
today
the virus can stop with us um we need to
do what we can to make sure that we
break those chains of transmission
let the virus first of all let you not
get infected
but if you are infected let the virus
stop with you
thank you uh so much i would like now to
call
on jason bobia from uh public
radio public national radio npr to ask
the next question
jason can you hear me yes thank you very
much
um i wanted to ask uh about the the
variant the b117 which originated out of
the uk
um there's a a lot of concern about
how transmissible it actually is what do
you have in terms of clarity on
exactly how much more transmissible this
is
and is there adequate monitoring
globally to actually
detect this um that this
these changes and report these variants
thanks
thank you yes thank you for the question
so the
virus variant in the identified in the
united kingdom this b117
we are working with our colleagues in
the uk and in fact as we sit here
uh just now they've just released their
third technical briefing
um online that come that has just come
out from public health england
we meet with our colleagues regularly
there and they're looking at a variety
of factors related to this virus
variance
one of the issues they're looking at is
transmission and the way that they're
evaluating
transmission is looking at the data
captured through their surveillance
system
through the case through the the
molecular testing the pcr testing
the antigen-based testing but also the
amount
of cases that are sequenced they've done
some modeling studies
they've done some phylogenetic analysis
which is analysis of the
the full genome sequences that have been
made available across the country
and they're doing some studies in the
lab looking at the viral loads of
individuals with
infected with this variant compared to
other
cyrus kobe 2 viruses and what we
understand from their studies that are
ongoing
and again these are ongoing studies and
they're constantly updated with more
information
is that the virus variant this b117
is more transmissible than the wild type
sars cov2 viruses
and they have estimated through their
modeling studies that the
increase in transmissibility is measured
as measured by the reproduction number
which is the amount of the number of
cases an infected individual would
infect
has increased from about 1.1 to about
1.5
or 1.7 that's also been analyzed through
the phylogenetic data
they've seen increases in transmission
across all age groups
and that's a reflection of the mixing
patterns and the transmission
that has happened in southeast england
in london
and across other parts of the uk they've
also measured viral load
which is the amount of virus detected
through the testing systems that they
have
and they have found that people who have
been infected with the virus variant the
b117
have a higher viral load compared to
others
with the the wild-type virus but we did
specifically speak today
about the way the virus transmits or the
modes of transmission
and there is no difference in the way
that this virus transmits
and that's important because we need to
constantly look at the measures that are
in place
the personal protective equipment that
is being advised
they are discussing that with their
expert groups in the uk and they have
not changed their recommendations on
ppe um but it does mean if you have
a virus that is more easily transmitted
you have to work that much harder in
breaking those chains of transmission
it is important to note that the tools
that we have against
normal sars cov2 virus which is
dangerous enough
work against the virus variant that was
identified in the united kingdom and
separately also against the virus
variant that was identified in south
africa as well
so they are continuing to do studies
we're very grateful for all of the
collaboration
across public health england and the
many different academic groups and
modeling groups and
the frontline workers and the studies
that are ongoing and and i
quite literally are sharing this with
these results with us in real time
so thanks for that question but a little
an increase in transmissibility
no change in disease presentation or
severity
which i don't think that i mentioned but
that is that has been confirmed through
the cohort study that they've
have ongoing um looking at rates of
hospitalization so no change and
hospitalization from people
infected with the virus variant compared
to the other sars cov2 viruses
or immortality yeah
and just to add that wh and partners
were fully activated on monitoring the
the emergence of
variance and the evolution of this virus
and have been for months with the virus
evolution
or working group which involves
scientists and labs
from from all over the world we are
issuing guidance to countries on how
today
thank you maria on specific
epidemiologic and laboratory
surveillance for these variants
which is supplementary to previous
advice
put out there our global epi team is
working on a
epidemiologic analysis right now looking
at signals
uh for unusual epidemiologic events that
may be occurring in relation to variants
around the world and it's important that
our work is epidemiologically driven
and that we're using epidemiology to
drive our lab investigations
and as i said the virus evolution
working group continues to work
the the vaccines group is is also
working very hard and next week there
will be a specific
research and development our projects
our program on research and development
for blueprint for epidemics we'll be
hosting
a meeting two meetings next week one
specifically to look at the
emergence of viral variants and one
looking specifically at the research
needed around vaccines
in relation to the same issues and
beyond the vaccines meeting is broader
but it will consider the variant
issues as well much work is underway as
well looking at
the the the long-term long-term
effectiveness or
or functioning of performance of
diagnostic tests
looking at the lab essays uh also
looking
at the continued effectiveness of
monoclonals and polyclonal antibodies
and then with vaccines so that work is
underway all of that needs to be
further brought together different very
important strands on this
but maria is correct we're not seeing a
clinical signal that this disease is
more severe
the evolutionary pressure on the virus
is gen is is
is and this is what viruses do they tend
to become fitter they become
better adapted to transmission in humans
and with higher viral loads
then they're more likely to cause
transmission that is in the interest of
the virus that's a
positive evolutionary outcome for the
virus not for us
in that regard there is no signal at
this point of any change in in clinical
severity and that's very important to
recognize we've also had meetings today
with our strategic and technical
advisory group on infectious hazards
which is chaired by david hayman from
the london school
we've considered these issues as well
next week we will have
our meeting of the emergency committee
on the ihr which will consider
these issues as well so the the
in addition we've been working with the
global influenza surveillance and
response system
the guest risk system has been providing
vital uh monitoring
of cobit 19 around the world through
[Music]
severe acute respiratory illness and
ili surveillance and we've been able to
track the
the overall impact and sort of presence
of cobit
around the world over the last number of
months we're currently working with them
to see how we can adapt that
and enhance that to do more of the
genetic monitoring
as well and in addition
working on expanding genetic sequencing
capacity around the world particularly
in low and middle income countries
and i know there are some excellent
projects out there led by the welcome
trust and others
looking at how we can rapidly further
expand the capacity to do genetic
sequencing and
genetic surveillance as such on this
virus so many many strands of activity
from the vaccines to the labs to the
epidemiology
to the transfer of knowledge and
technology and capacity and we will
continue to do so and keep you
informed of progress again though i
think it's important to recognize
that we've had variants before emerge
d614g
and and others and these variants and
will continue to emerge as the virus
evolves we're in a race against the
virus in that sense
but we should also remember as maria
said that the way in which this virus is
transmitting has not changed we still
have the capacity
to suppress that transmission if we do
the right things
and we will continue obviously to study
the long-term impact on any of these
variant variations on diagnosis
on therapies and on vaccines but rest
assured this is in hand and we are
looking very very closely at this
we take this these developments very
seriously
but we also need to remain focused on
the job at hand which is breaking chains
of transmission
and getting vaccines out to those who
need them thank you
um i think dr van kakov would like to
add something just to say we can share
the guidance that was issued today there
were two pieces of guidance that were
issued today related to sequencing
um we've had a lot of people ask us
questions about how much do we need to
sequence and how do we do that
so we've issued in our disease outbreak
news which is which was on the 31st of
december so preliminary
recommendations on who to who to
sequence which cases to sequence
recognizing that sequence capacity is
not at the level that we need it around
the world
and also that you don't need to sequence
every single case that's out there but
as mike has said leveraging the systems
around
we have really worked very hard with our
flu network to be able to
to build diagnostic capacity as well as
use the sequencing to do that
we've issued two guidance today one is a
interim
interim guidance which is
recommendations on who to test who to
sequence
and what we want to focus on is
sequencing a subset of cases
that are in your country based on
capacity but also especially focusing on
any cases that are part of clusters that
may be different than what you would
expect
for example in the united kingdom they
noticed that there was an increase in
transmission in late november early
december
when they didn't expect there to be
increased transmission because there
were some interventions in place
they were in tier two and tier three
lockdown and so they went back and
looked there and did some sequencing
but also if you see any change in
disease profile
difference or severity those would be
good cases to sequence that's a good
place to start
but we've issued some guidance with more
specificity in there
for the lab programs in each country to
look at and also we have a much larger
implementation guide on how to set up
sequencing
which is a much bigger project because
it's very labor intensive and quite
expensive but we're working with
countries to be able to
increase that capacity with the the
public health labs in country
but also leveraging academic labs and
private labs that can do sequencing as
well
because as you pointed out in your
question we need to be able to detect
and detection of these mutations and the
detection of these variants
comes from the full genome sequencing so
being able to do that
helps us have eyes on these viruses and
how the viruses change
but also sharing those viruses sharing
those sequences
with public databases like jose for
example
and that allows scientists all over the
world to do these beautiful trees and
phylogenetic analysis of actually
tracking it over time
so we as as mike has outlined as you've
heard us say
there's a comprehensive risk monitoring
framework
around mutations and variants
so that we can have the a robust process
to determine which ones are important
and why and what is the public health
impact of any of these that are
identified
so i just wanted to add one sorry for
taking the floor again
but uh as the uk you know have assigned
the value to this
calling it a variant of concern i think
it's important to reflect on that
there are lots and lots of different
variations in the virus and there are
many
if every virus you sequence will be
slightly different but the uk
have identified through epidemiologic
investigation first
and then identifying a variant was
associating that variant with the change
in the epidemiology
and then labeling that a variant of
concern and i think that's what we're
after we're after being able to detect
not just variations in the virus
but been specifically able to identify
variations of the virus that are
of of a concern for public health for
transmission
for for severity and that's the job
picking out of the noise picking the
needle in the haystack
picking out the signal from the virus as
it evolves whether
new versions of the virus evolve that
are of more concern for us
in terms of our ability to control us or
in terms of its
severity and again just to say the
governments of the united kingdom and of
south africa
and others in nigeria and other
countries are doing a fantastic job
in stepping up on this issue of genetic
surveillance and
monitoring this at a much more enhanced
level and therefore
it's really important that we when we
people call this a uk variant or south
africa
that we're not assigning values to these
countries these countries are not the
cause of this problem they're actually
defining solutions by giving us the
information that we need and they should
be commended and lauded
for having invested in the kinds of
systems that allow us to do this kind of
monitoring
we should be following their example
rather than looking
at these as problems generated by are
are
in south africa or in the united kingdom
the government the public health the
labs clinicians and others in those
countries
should be and i think south africa is a
beacon in terms of the com
the comprehensiveness of the way south
africa has been able to pull together
data from many many different sources
again shows that this old idea of the
north south divide
the countries in the south can't do as
well as countries in the north when it
comes to doing this hardcore
epidemiology and lab this is about
access to technology other countries in
the south can do this
as well they don't necessarily have
access to the technology and the
training and the resources to do it
but south africa has clearly shown
nigeria have clearly shown
that if they have those resources if
they have access to these technologies
they will get on and do exactly the same
job as is done in the north
[Music]
thank you i would like now to invite
kathleen fionko
bukonga to ask the next question
catherine can you hear me
yes thank you fadela thank you for
giving me the floor
my question is is regarding the types of
vaccines
if i can express myself sorry because
i'm not a scientific
um you have um africa
that has problems um to to
get access to the vaccines for the
moment are turning
uh to the chinese sino farm
vaccine and the guinea start
started vaccination with sputnik 5.
so could you give us more information
about those vaccines um
and also maybe the price because if i
understood
the vaccines like pfizer and moderna
that are using a new technology are 10
times more expensive
that's um astrazeneca oxford or the one
that are using a more traditional
method of vaccine thank you so much for
your answers
uh merci katrin i would like to invite
maybe dr edward to to start
sure thank you uh catherine so you've
asked about the
uh types of vaccines now dr
um tedros in his opening comments
highlighted that there's 42 countries
around the world that we know
are now vaccinating with cova 19
vaccines the majority of these of course
in the industrialized world and there's
been very limited
or sorry in high-income countries and a
small number in the upper middle income
countries about six
it's very limited if any vaccination a
lot of you what you've referred to are
actually plans not actually the rollout
of products yet and sometimes they're
just exploratory discussions
but in the places that have started
vaccinating there's been six
vaccines that are in use right now the
the the among them the ones that you
mentioned
and these are a range of vaccines from
mrna vaccines as you said all the way to
inactivated vaccine products at this
point we're aware of
two of those vaccines that have gone
through stringent regulatory authorities
in multiple countries one approved by a
stringent regulatory authority
in one country one has been
let's say emergency use listed by who
and that is the pfizer product that
we've seen
others in the pipeline now for
evaluation very very
rapidly we are aware that some countries
have made decisions to proceed with
vaccines that have been approved through
other
mechanisms we recognize that and we are
continuing to work with both the
countries to support the decision-making
that they may
make in that regard and understanding
the issues around that
but we're also working very hard with
the companies that are producing these
products
to make sure that they can be assessed
by uh
w.h.o through its uh its
uh its uh regulatory support processes
so
um in the process of looking uh looking
at those products
as you know we are not in a position to
provide a
perspective on vaccines that are in use
that we've not seen the data on
and at this point as i say the vaccine
that we have seen
is the pfizer vaccine we have all of the
data on that
we also recognize of course in this
exceptional circumstance
vaccines that have been approved through
stringent regulatory authorities and now
those are
the pfizer vaccine the moderna vaccine
and then
one country having approved one other
vaccine at this point
through a stringent regulatory authority
um i think marie antoinette wanted that
can i just compliment from the
regulatory side
first of all countries have the autonomy
to according to their legislation to
issue emergency use authorization for
health products according to their own
registration
but double joe does have a process that
most of you are aware of which is the
the pre-qualification process
and in the case of vaccines new vaccines
like the
the covid vaccines we we do an emergency
use listing assessment
we have issued an expression of interest
received 13
valid uh proposals in
since october and besides the pfizer
vaccine who was already listed by wgo
we do have other products that are in at
advanced stage
and specifically in the products that
you have
cited we have received already and this
information is public it's published in
wgo's website
we have received a for example the fudos
here from cino farm who has finalized
it a phase three trial and it's been
authorized in some countries we are in
the process of receiving
the complete data from astrazeneca from
the serene institute and we we expect to
receive additional data from the
the gamalia which is the russian a
producer
before the end of january so this is
just to say that these products are
currently
being assessed by wj and this is
important not only because
many countries rely on wgo's assessment
for
for uh authorizing the use of the
product
in their own countries but also because
it helps the international procures like
unicef and others to
to procure the vaccines that have been
assessed by the region
thank you thank you i think that
dr edward would like to add something
yeah i just will also want to come back
in on on the point
that uh when people ask our opinion on
these products
i that that i'm i'm sure you the
journalists with us today would
appreciate
for us to provide an opinion on a
product that we've actually not seen and
seen the data behind would be
inappropriate uh and and unfair to those
asking the opinion
we also have to be very clear though you
know that a neutral perspective right
some
of these products may turn out to be
great products extremely important in
the battle against
coven 19. and this comes back to a point
that the director general
made in his opening comments um we've
put together a fantastic
facility to help make sure vaccines get
rolled out
equitably around the world the the
fundamentals are completely sound
that mechanism can only work if vaccines
come into it and go through it as well
as
money we don't print money and we don't
make vaccines
this is where we need the manufacturers
working with us
and we need the countries the donor
countries and others working with us and
working together
if a company does not submit the data
that we need
it is slowing equitable access to
vaccines around the world
if a company doesn't sign and work the
deals through with us
and if we don't have the financing to do
it they're slowing equitable
access and the director general i think
was very frank about that today and what
we're calling for and there's a
frank uh call to action in the director
general speech
is access to the data on all of these
products
in real time as it's coming out so that
we can ensure
that we can provide a perspective on
these products as rapidly as possible
and get them out equitably around the
world you know michael asked an
excellent question earlier and then
maria was responding to it talking about
the tools
and the problem we have is the tools
aren't equitably distributed
look at the map of the world there's a
huge part of the world that's not
vaccinating yet
50 percent of the high income countries
in the world
are vaccinating today zero percent of
the low-income
countries are vaccinating that is not
equitable access
especially when we know and mike made
this point
that the people at risk of dying are
older people
there's older people everywhere in the
world the people at risk of
most exposure to this are those front
line workers
these people are working around the
world but they're not being protected at
the same rates
that's why we've created kovacs it is
there
it works what it needs are the vaccines
and financing we have part of the
financing in place we are ready to go
ready to get started we need the
manufacturers working with us
we need the countries working with us we
have to change the color of those maps
this month
thank you dr ellward um i think that
dr o'brien has also something to add uh
dr o'brien yeah just two things to add
to what uh
has already been said by bruce and by um
mariangela
the two additional points i i want to
add have to do with transparency
and have to do with policy so in
addition to the procurement
um so the money that uh that bruce has
spoken about
and the need for the data on uh
regulatory issues um in in addition
countries do rely
on who for recommendations on how to use
the
vaccines especially because these
vaccines are in limited supply
in the initial phase of rollout we know
that all over the world
choices do need to be made about how
best to use them to their best
impact their most maximum impact
especially in these very early phases
and we do need to see the data on these
products in order to establish policies
as sage did at the beginning
of this of this week the second thing is
transparency on information
our our understanding of which countries
where they're using vaccines
what deals are being done is extremely
important
in order to help with this whole process
of equitable allocation
and equitable access to vaccines and
we're also
calling on countries and manufacturers
to be clear
about and transparent about where
vaccines
deals are being done the doses that are
being
arranged for use in various countries
and then their actual rollout and having
this information over time
is really important for uh who
and for the world to respond to this
crisis in a way that will
have its maximum impact so i think those
are the two other points to make here
thank you um thank you all
i would like now to invite christopher
hamill stewart from arab news
to ask the next question uh christopher
hi can you hear me yes very well go
ahead please great thank you um i
wondered if the
who had a response to
iran's announcement today that it would
ban the import of u.s
and uk vaccines
thank you uh christopher dr o'brien do
you want to
respond to this question please
um as bruce has just indicated there are
a number of vaccines
on on the market that are available
around the world
and especially in the kovacs facility
um uh the importance of having a
portfolio of vaccines
that serve the different needs of
different countries and especially
serving the different uh needs of
delivery situations we know from
uh of the different products that we
have some require an ultra cold chain
some require a frozen temperature that's
not ultra cold
um and some require refrigeration so we
have
a lot of variability of the products in
terms of
a range of their characteristics um i
think the other important thing to say
in relation to this is that there is
manufacturing going on of these products
in different places around the world
and that provides greater or lesser
access
to different vaccines and so i think the
range of needs of countries
and choices of countries is served by
having this portfolio of vaccines
where there can be matching of vaccines
to
the delivery needs and the
characteristics that countries
uh have for the the access to those
vaccines
um thank you dr ellward i think wanted
to compliment
yeah thank you fidella and thanks kate
um super important questions right about
vaccines and vaccine access that we keep
coming back to and we're going to come
back to them more and more as we go
forward over the coming months
and the important thing to recognize is
that every country in the world is
making decisions about what products it
it does and doesn't want to use and
prioritize and doesn't prioritize for
different reasons
and one of the things that we've been
doing as part of the kovacs facility is
going out and talking to
the 90 plus countries that are what we
call our amc countries and our other
participants we have 190 participants
and we get back a wide range of
preferences on what kind of products
they want to use whether they want to
use more than one product or two
products um which particular products
they may want to use and for a whole
wide range
of uh of uh reason so you know i come
back to that perspective that the
director general comes back to again and
again
about the importance of um not singling
out
individual countries or issues and
really focusing on how do we get these
products to as many countries
as necessary and you know one of the
beauties of the kovacs facility the way
we set it up is we've got a very broad
portfolio of products
we know we have a broad range of clients
that we're working with through that
participants
and what we're going to do is work with
them to get that right balanced products
and again it's one of the reasons that
this facility is such an important part
of the global solution
to equitable access and rollout every
country needs these products
every economy needs these products right
now and it's really time to put um you
know any kind of politic aside and make
sure that vaccines get to the people
that need them
i think bruce bruce said that the dg has
said
many times in the past let us not
politicize this virus
please let us not politicize this
vaccine either
thank you i would like now to invite fa
antonio broto
to ask the next question antonio can you
hear me
yes can you hear me yes very well go
ahead please
thank you favela for taking my question
so
global figures for daily cases of kobe
in the first days of this year
are not higher than in december despite
the fear to a spike in transmissions
after the christmas and new year
holidays so do you think this is a good
sign
maybe a sign that the vaccines are
already working
or is it too soon to be that optimistic
thank you i think it's uh way too soon
to be that optimistic look the reality
is for the third week in a row
we've had over four million cases
reported each week
in this pandemic and there's been a very
slight decrease
in the last week but again the
transmissions that would have occurred
over the holiday period will only be
pushing through into the
numbers that we're seeing this week next
week
and beyond so uh no it is way too early
to
to to interpret that what we do know is
in certainly in the northern hemisphere
there's been a tremendous amount of
mixing of people
over the last number of weeks and as has
been previously stated
we're dealing with the complications of
various strains and potential increases
in trans
transmission so no there is there's
nothing to suggest that the number of
vaccines that
have currently been distributed will
have had zero impact on transmission
dynamics
at country level they may are saying
maybe are saving lives
as we speak and we're very grateful for
that but they're not going to affect
transmission dynamics for a very long
time
bruce it might fit out just to the point
that mike
meant the last point was so important
the last part of that question right
about
whether or not we're seeing the impact
of the vaccines already and the answer
is
no these vaccines and the way we're
rolling them out have two
really specific goals our first save
lives
get them to the people at highest risk
of dying of this disease
we know those populations they're the
older people in our society
so important that they get protected
early right
we know the people who are getting
exposed at a disproportionate rate
and especially those frontline workers
who unfortunately have been given their
lives to try and save lives during this
crisis we've got to protect those people
first so that's what our initial goals
are
we do not have the volumes they don't
exist yet and we also don't know all the
mechanisms of these vaccines
to be having an impact on on these
curves
much much to worry and as we look into
our crystal balls right
um we're not going to see that in the
coming six months this
is as we scale up these vaccines over
time it comes back again and again to
what mike has been saying the director
general
we this is not going to work if people
are
mixing at high rates if they're not
using masks if they're not doing all
those things that are so
important vaccines have a lot of promise
but what need to do now is identify the
cases rapidly the mild cases the
moderate cases that are driving this
crisis get them isolated
identify the contacts get them
quarantined that plus the rollout of the
vaccines
is what is going to see those curves
change but
it's not going to change just by those
drops of vaccines that are going out at
the current rates um
and they're only going to go out we've
seen all the challenges to getting the
numbers up
even in highly advanced uh uh um
you know uh environments so it
is uh absolutely imperative that the
other parts of this response
work and we start applying the knowledge
we've learned in the 12 months that
we've known this virus
thank you maria yes thank you so we i
have to
you know come in on the aspects of you
know the consequences of our action and
the director general said it in his
speech tonight
um the the results of these our actions
over the last five
six weeks is what is resulting in
increased case numbers and increased
hospitalizations
and increased numbers of deaths and that
will continue for the coming weeks
and the coming months if we do not
change our behavior
in you have to follow the local advice
that is in that is being advised in the
areas where you live
um governments need to enable
populations to be able to do so
if you are asked to stay home we
understand that that is challenging
uh in many different respects of our
daily lives and our social lives
and many situations people need to work
to put food on the table so we need
people to be supported in the actions
that are advised by governments
but we also need individuals to think
about what they do
every single day the decisions that you
make
every single day about what you want to
do versus what you need to do
matter they can have consequences of
increasing transmission
and they can have consequences of
decreasing transmission
please help be part of the solution of
decreasing transmission
there are actions that you can take
right now that limit the exposure to
yourself
and to your loved ones and maybe you
don't think that that covet covid19 is a
big deal for you
but it can be because we know that this
virus is dangerous
this virus can cause severe disease and
it can kill you
and maybe not you maybe someone that you
love that has an underlying condition or
as of older age
this is serious and at the present time
in many countries we are seeing
increased transmission where we can turn
the corner
by putting in the measures at home
staying home if you're unwell
staying home and not mixing with other
families postponing that trip that all
of us want to take
making sure that all of the actions that
are put in place if you are asked
to be in quarantine please stay in
quarantine
you are adding to the solution here if
you are a case and we hope there are no
more cases
but if you are a case staying in
isolation making sure that you receive
the adequate care that you need
in in medical facilities allowing the
the researcher the
the community workers to do contact
tracing and cluster investigation
and the technicians to do those lab
tests and get those test results back
quicker
but all of these actions can reduce
transmission
and we are pleading with everyone to do
everything that they can
to be part of the solution to to break
those chains of transmission
it is within our hands vaccines and
vaccination are another
powerful tool but it will take time in
the meantime
there is much that you can do every
single day so please help be part of the
solution
thank you maria i think that dr o'brien
wanted to say a few words
dr o'brien you have the flow yeah i just
want to add to uh what
you know really important things that uh
everybody has said about this um maria
in particular just now
um but we we've been saying about the
vaccines um even anticipating that they
were coming even before that they
they came that uh it was not gonna be a
flip of the switch
and even as they roll out we actually
don't have the information right now
about the
the magnitude the degree to which they
actually interrupt transmission
and so although we do have evidence now
about the degree to which they might
they can't check against disease and
especially severe disease
um that does not necessarily imply that
the same magnitude of impact
will be on uh the the protection against
transmitting from one person to the next
person so i just want to reinforce that
even for people who have been vaccinated
and there will be an ever increasing
number of those people
that does not mean that people who have
been vaccinated are
are are now fully protected from getting
infected in their nose
they are are very substantially
protected against
themselves becoming ill but we have
evidence that a very
uh a new study with 59 percent estimate
from a model
of the transmission is coming from
people who are not symptomatic
at that point in time so we really do
need
as we roll out the vaccines to to
remember
as maria has said this is just one tool
a new tool and a very powerful tool
in the tool kit but it doesn't mean that
we should step back in fact we should be
escalating and improving our use of all
the other tools that we already have
thank you
thank you dr o'brien antonio's question
was the last one for today over to you
dr tedros for final words thank you
thank you thank you so much fedilla
thank you all uh
colleagues from the media for joining
and look forward to seeing you in our
upcoming pressure
have a nice weekend and happy new year
thank you just reminding journalists
that we will be sending the audio file
and the dg speech right after this press
conference
the full transcript will be posted soon
on the wto website
as usual uh do not hesitate to contact
the media team
uh if you wish uh to ask the follow-up
question
thank you and have a nice weekend
you